cool
die identität zu landen wir haben es bei
den dragons gesehen sie verstehen sich
nicht nur aus stimme gegen islamische
einflüsse
sie wehren sich auch gegen das
angebliche diktat der amerikanischen
kultur und dies natürlich nirgends
plakat ifa präsent aus dem pariser
disneyland genau dort untersucht die
künstlerin marion wallach die
befindlichkeit junger franzosen marie
und relativ schnelles finden was mit
menschen geschieht die direkt neben
einer traumwelt aufwachsen
das ist der eingang zum park noch nicht
zum park selber und bereits hier spürt
man die atmosphäre des disney universums
in meinem film gibt es jedoch keine
märchen bogen oder zauberschloss ich
habe mich viel mehr auf die kleine
details konzentriert
der kunst film lesung wurde wiederum
zeigt keine touristenmassen er dreht
sich um die anwohner des prags die man
im film aber nie zu gesicht bekommt man
hört nur ihre stimmen
auszüge von interviews die marion
ballack mit ihnen geführt hat viele der
interviewten anwohner hatten früher oder
später einen job
[Musik]
sie kommen die große die fiktion und die
realität treffen hier aufeinander
das war schon sehr überraschend für mich
und wenn man hier lebt man wohl oder
übel dieses disney universum eingezogen
es sind jetzt sozusagen eine totale
fiktionalisierung der gegen statt
[Musik]
mario barth lebt in paris
35 kilometer von eurodisney entfernt in
ihrer kunst nutzt sie unterschiedliche
medien die sie oft im internet vorfindet
sie sammelt daten und bilder und
schaffte auf neue situationen
dabei geht es ihr stets um
soziokulturelle fragen in ihrem
aktuellen film zeigt sie das ambivalente
verhältnis der anwohner zum benachbarten
park es ist eine art hassliebe sogar die
kritischen stimmen hatten immer auch
einen positiven bezug zum disneyland
es ist als wären die anwohner gefangen
zwischen zwei identitäten zwischen der
regionalen französischen und der einer
us amerikanischen firma jeden tag rund
um den park präsent ist zb mit solchen
schicken wohngegend im film dienen
google street view wäre als metapher für
die überwachung dieser sicheren gegend
enders weiter robbie ist im vergleich zu
seiner umgebung ein behütetes utopia in
bester venezianischer kulisse während
ein paar kilometer weiter die
berüchtigten pariser banlieues liegen
lässt man sich sehr gut ging
[Musik]
die leute finden hier eine wohngegend
vor die sicherheit und ruhe verspricht
eine art künstliche blase und das ist es
auch was die leute gleich nebenan im
disneyland vorführen es ist genauso ein
ort wo man abgeschnitten ist von der
welt beide hat mit der eigentlichen
realität nichts zu tun
[Musik]
der unterhaltungskonzern dringt tief in
das leben seiner anwohner ein
dieser kunst film zeigt dass es auf
subtile art
[Musik]